I am single but I'm I'm not ready for
mingling yet a lot has changed since
then Nikki Bella has been enjoying
playing the dating game over the last
few months and it looks like her ex John
Cena is not too far behind yeah John was
recently spotted packing on the PDA with
a mystery woman who has now been
identified as che sherry out today
now nikki is opening up on her and
sister Brees the Bellas podcast about
how she really felt after seeing those
paparazzi photos when I saw the headline
because it was text to me by a few
people my stomach went into knots okay
girls and guys we all can talk about
this right you know sometimes when you
get a text or you see a photo or you see
your other significant other flirt with
someone or something you know you get
those knots in your stomach that hurts
like you only want to poop your pants
like immediately or you just have the
craziest tummy ache great yeah I vomit
or usually what happens so neither of
that happened to me when I set aside a
lot so I gotta find it hard yeah leave
that she had no effect after seeing the
photo I mean they were fiance friend you
would feel some kind of way if you end
on your bad terms I also think any
celebrity who has to constantly see
their ex with other people in the media
is hard nobody wants to do it in regular
life but imagine being a celebrity and
seeing it splashed all over tabloids and
on the Internet yeah but to be fair John
and Nikki did call it quits nearly 1
year ago and this is the part that
confuses me at one point Nikki seems
hopeful that they would reconcile do you
think there's any hope at all that these
two would ever get back together
I don't know Never Say Never it's hard
because they feel differently about kids
that was the thing that really broke
them up John and I we absolutely love
each other and we care about each other
a lot we are best friends and right now
we're both giving each other time
separately and maybe there's hope that
we reunite in the future Nikki admits
she felt her reality show gave a
one-sided view of the breakup and she
empathizes with John it made me sad for
John and I felt bad for John with our
breakup I felt bad because I felt like I
embarrassed him I felt like I
disappointed him after a tough public
split Nikki says she goes to weekly
therapy and of course she's the
[Music]
the total Bella star sparked a romance
rumors with her Dancing with the Stars
partner Artem and while things seemed to
be heating up between the two and Nikki
confirmed on the premiere episode of
twins podcast
she and Artem are not exclusive
interesting yes we are dating yes they
spend the night at his house yes we have
date lunches at Joan's on third Artem
and I are dating o YH for not marry and
we're not boyfriend and girlfriend we
don't say I love you exclusive or not
the chemistry was now clear between
Nikki and Artem while she was engaged I
know well we spend a lot of time
together and they need a lot from us and
so I'm someone who when that happens I
kind of shut down but Artem knows how to
break through me and he's really like
learned how to like let my guard down
and so I used like my Russian therapist
it's great okay so how long do we think
Nikki is going to casually date kinda
want her and Artem to get serious oh my
god really yeah I like them together
they have good chemistry I think her and
John are dunzo for good he doesn't want
kids she wants to be a mom yeah
the deal-breaker yeah I could see that
but I want Mickey and Artem to take it
slow if anything okay that's fair that's
fair what do you guys think though let
us know and of course we will keep you
updated on all the latest with this
Bella babe be sure to subscribe to ET
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and I'm
Courtney tezo
[Music]